A,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday, February 27th, 2017 what's going
one on how are you ?
how's it going? Sorry, the podcast is a little bit late this week. Um, you know,
the fucking checkout was, you know,
10:00 AM at this place I was staying at and I thought I could sleep till 10 and
then do the fucking podcasts and leave at noon. That's what I thought. You know,
I'm sorry. Am I still in America? Checkout time is maybe 11.
Where the fuck is it? 10:00 AM
the fuck is Trump not president anymore? I mean,
I thought this was something that he thought he thought he was gonna make it
great again. Make it great again.
That'd be check out at one in the fucking afternoon.
Once you sign an executive order. If order for that orange headed content.
How about that? This podcast is not funny. It's sad.
It's a lonely man by himself. I'm sorry for the bad Trump impression.
Um, anyways, I am in Gainesville, Florida right now. You're probably wondering,
Bill, what the fuck are you doing in Gainesville, Florida,
home with the Florida gators? You know,
you're on there either on a fucking Monday. It's not football season.
Why are you here?
It's cause I have to do the makeup date for the show that I was going to do back
in November when I was going to go to the Florida gators game down there at the
fucking swamp.
I was going to do that and go to the Florida gator LSU game.
And um, that game got rained out. Whatever.
They had a fucking hurricane and everybody freaked out cause Jacksonville was
going to get the shit kicked out of him. Gay Gainesville was, you know,
as far as I'm concerned it was safe, you know,
with my complete lack of a meteorology logical background.
Is that the right word? I Dunno. So I'm back here. I'm back here, you know,
in February. Well, nothing's going on. Oh Shit.
What about that team?
What if they fuck a team has a good basketball team as a game tonight?
Maybe that's, maybe that's what's going on. I don't fucking know. Anyways.
Um, I'm here in fucking day. Uh, Gainesville, uh,
had a great time this whole weekend being out there and now Daytona,
Daytona Beach, Florida, and uh, Jesus Christ, dude,
some of the fucking locals in Daytona. Yeah. Heart just goes out to,
you know what I mean? It's just these, these fight all these dudes.
It's all those people that, that people in Hollywood trash,
you know what I mean? It's just a bunch of, you know,
a lot of fucking white people that just,
Jesus' life is just fucking kicked the shit out of them.
Not saying everybody, but I'm just saying,
I fucking came into town
fucking walking down the street the first night I got video of this. I'm,
I'm walking.
There's like a fight about rate of breakout outside of a pizza joint and
everybody there was like my age, except they look my age, you know what I mean?
They might have a better hairline, which isn't hard with me,
but they're just fucking fat.
Yeah.
Fucking big fat fucking, uh, what's that pride, those sex shit that people eat?
That is it called that Shit Larry,
the cable guy talks about right where he goes fucking proud six 18 seat.
When you fucking go out and you eat a whole fucking pig and you stomach's like,
what the fuck you just do to me rather than natty the whole fucking pig again.
You can take this shit and make it feel like eating a whole pig itself is okay.
That shit, they had those bodies,
lot of cargo shorts that were just frayed at the bottom. A lot of bad tattoos.
A lot of fucking people that look like, even if they weren't on drugs,
you know when people do drugs for so fucking long,
there's only so coherent that you can get back to.
We went to this fucking restaurant right on the Strip and uh,
this fucking lady, Jesus Christ, if she wasn't high, she just don't,
she had just done so many fucking drugs. She bought the fucking wings over.
Right. And they were like, they weren't ice cold. They will room temperature,
which is fucking ice cold. And I'm like, yeah. Uh, and I hate sending food back.
We're sitting in this fucking restaurant, right. And we sitting in a,
it's like basically a NASCAR, cause we're,
they had to go to the Daytona 500 the next day. Right.
It's like a NASCAR that they cut in half and put a booth in the middle of it.
Right.
Um,
assumption. I don't know what the fuck it is.
And we looked up later and evidently this was the worst restaurant
me and Nate ended up going to this fucking thing.
Ended up being the worst restaurant. It wasn't bad. I ordered the fucking,
it looks shady and the music they were playing,
they were playing like Zz top. She's got legs.
They played George through a good twice. Uh,
they played yes. Owner of a lonely heart. I was just sitting there. It fell.
He goes,
in 1985 I was joking on stage that night I was waiting for fucking Marty McFly
to come walking in key word there,
fly and um,
to see some guy walking around sort of mouthing the words to this joint.
It wasn't even a good George Story. Good Song.
It wasn't bad to the bone or a whatever that fucking was one whiskey,
one scotch or one beer wasn't that one. It was at, uh,
the cover day that my bag dog,
my bitch don't come no more booming on over rock and on over.
It just said, I gone, oh my God.
Um,
the waitress fucked up every possible way she could have fucked up other than
just blowing your nose into the bread. I mean, other than that, she,
every fucking thing you could do, she fucked up. It was hilarious. I've,
I felt bad for, I could see, you know, she just, you know, we all do it.
We all do it in business. We stay out there too long. Madonna did it, you know,
she's still twerk and she's like 60.
It's like Madonna for the love of fucking God. Can you dress your age?
Okay Kid,
you have a shred of fucking decency for yourself so that people can just in a
general sense, look in your, your, your direction. You know what I mean?
There was a bunch of guys down on Daytona beach dressing the way Madonna was
dressing.
There was a bunch of fucking guys my age still wearing tank tops where your arms
have no muscle definition anymore. It's just us.
It looks like in order it looks like, it looks like,
you know when somebody has like cankles you know that part of the leg where it
just, you know, there's no shape to the calf.
That's what the arm looks like and it's all fucking flabby and just these awful
horrific fucking tattoos. I'm just shit.
And you pick off a wall,
somebody with the shakes just puts it on your fucking rms. So she comes over,
by the way, when you go into a place like that, cause once I sit down,
I'm not leaving. Just go with the grilled cheese.
You get a grilled cheese sandwich and what can they do? You know what I mean?
Fucking Nate ordered a Hamburg and I was just like, all right dude. You know,
but if you get fucking a bola,
I mean I don't want to hear your bitching about it or whatever. We equal lie,
whatever you get. And it was something with knee.
So she comes over and she's just like, Hey, well,
it was like one in the afternoon, the sun just fucking blaze into the windows.
He's just like, Hey, welcome. We're going to be a waitress to this is evening,
evening.
And she caught herself saying evening and she just fucking plowed forward. Uh,
you know, your guys' patch to third. Uh, then it was like, listen,
it was like literally like listening to a cell phone going in and out. Right.
And um,
she brings the fucking orders over and she kept going, how, how's your meat?
Which I've never heard anybody say that. I order a burger and the wings,
I've got a little dangerous with the fucking wings.
And I had the grilled cheese sandwich.
I think it was just too much for a fucking blown out brain to try to remember
what kind of protein we ordered.
So she just kept coming over and going as the inmate, she came over,
she gave me the Burger,
she gave Nate the fucking grilled cheese sandwich way to swing that fucking
thing around. The chicken was fucking stone cold.
And she says she started to like turn sideways when she fucked up the order and
she was like almost trying to hide behind her own shoulder. She was like, ah,
I'm sorry,
I have the manager take it off and really apologize and she fucking disappears
and comes back two seconds later, which was a big thing in Daytona
ordering food that should have taken at least 15 minutes.
And it returned in like two seconds.
It was very disturbing because the first night when we saw those fucking old
guys with the flabby arms pushing each other outside that fucking pizza parlor.
Um, well
let me, I'll take you through the whole fucking shit show.
We went into this place that we thought was a Hooters,
a fucking Hooters. And I'm like, I'm not eating it here.
Any place that that is sort of in the sex industry.
It's got one foot in the sex industry. I'm not ordering food.
And so I went in there and got a beer and we walked in and the chicks didn't
have holders,
but they all had asses and they had shorts like up their ass.
Like half their fucking ass was hanging out. And it was just, you know,
it was a shit show. And we're trying to figure it out. We're like going,
what the fuck?
What the kind of fucking Hooters is holders finally admitting that hip hop went
mainstream about 25 years ago and now they're focusing on ashes.
And um, wasn't until the next day we walked out,
we realized it wasn't a Hooters. It was some wings joint and a,
I think they're going to put Hooters out of business cause I don't think people
care about tidies anymore. You know what I mean?
Plus you can have a nice rack and like your fucking ass could be as flat as a
Goddamn fucking desk desktop. Right. You know what I mean?
So then, then what do you guys, then you just gotta, you gotta get pair of tits,
you know, what do you, what are you gonna do with that?
I love an ass.
And you can't have a nice ass and be out of shape but just doesn't fucking work.
That is the nucleus of the body. If that's fucking in shape,
then everything else is fine. You could have a fucking pair of tits on.
You get what I mean? And it could just be a shit show when you go south.
You know what I mean? That's like a, you know guys, when they fucking, they,
they keep lifting weights, you know,
and they just keep trying to keep their chest out in front of their beer belly
and they keep pushing the jeans down further and further.
So they still have that 32 inch Jains you know, by the way,
I think white people were the first one to wear saggy jeans. You know,
I think we were the first ones to do it.
And that was with the guys who just refuse to buy a 34 inch to 36 38 inch waist.
They just kept pushing it down and letting their fucking stomach come out over
the top. So anyways,
she's like hiding behind her shoulder, going on inside the manager,
take it out of there. So she fucking, uh, oh no, I know.
I remember I was trying to see how quickly the food came.
So the night before we went out, after we left the fucking, uh,
the bar where these girls had to walk around with half of their fucking hazards
hanging out. Um, and now that I'm a dad,
it was even worse. I just kept thinking,
what if my daughter ends up working this for what?
I wanted to meet the father of all these guys and be like,
what did you do that had them end up here? So I don't do it.
So my daughter doesn't end up here. So we go down the fucking street and uh,
we go to this other fucking bar, do like they got a biker bar down there,
cause you know,
Daytona has that fucking crazy bike or we can some shit out here.
And I'm just like, all right,
I am not a biker and I'm not going to go in there and get fucking, you know,
I don't know. A pool, cute fucking shoved in my year. I don't need this shit.
Right. So we go to this other bar, it's sort of a sports bar. We walk in,
everything's cool. So I ordered some food, I go, let me get the,
uh, what's, what's the raw tuna? It's not Shashimi as a tuna tar, tar,
tar, tar. Is that what I ordered? You know, and,
and you know this fucking sports bar. Why would you,
why would you order raw fish in a place like that? It's fucking nuts.
But I did and I ordered chips and salsa and I swear to gut,
this woman walked into the kitchen. They had the in, in the outdoor, you know,
the swinging doors.
She walked in there and the Dolan permit [inaudible] and then she came walking
right back out and with the fucking food, like to like disturbingly,
like it came back so fucking fast. The look on my face, Nate was fucking crying,
laughing. And, uh,
all I can say about the food is you shouldn't have to chew raw tuna.
It should be like butter, like melts in your mouth kind of thing. And I,
and I was chewing this shit out of it.
So anyways, back to the fucking other places. You know,
this is so stupid that I'm fucking shitting on the food there.
When you're sitting in a fucking NASCAR that's been cut in half and they put a
fucking booth in the middle of it, can you really complain about the food? Well,
you know what, I have an hour to fill here. So I've gotten, um,
so this poor woman who, you know, probably had some Shitty Dad,
she ended up doing drugs, is trying to get our fucking order right.
And you know,
the guys walking around and the words moving on over and uh,
this guy in the corner starts eating this burger dude.
And I can't even tell the way he was fucking attacking this burger.
I was crying, laughing and I had to let you know I had to do like that,
you know,
you know when you're with somebody and you're the person you're laughing at kind
of catches you looking at them and then you want your friend to look at them
too. So you gotta do like that kind of that stretch thing where you look back.
Fortunately it was a flat flat screen TV above his head and I just sort of like
without even like I'm from toilet Christian,
so I'm like just turn around and look at the today. You know,
did like one of those things and dude,
the way this guy would say he attacked this burger, like he,
he lunged at it rather than like, it was almost like his,
it was someone else was holding,
it was the woman who was trying to steal a bite of somebody else's burger.
That's the way this guy was eating.
Like his first bite into the Burger. He fucking lunged at, it's so hard.
He hit himself in the face with like the lettuce that this big piece of like
fucking Romaine lettuce hanging off to sell whatever the fuck it was.
Iceberg lettuce. And when he lunged in at it,
like it fucking hit him in one of his eyes and he had a stop and blink and then
he just fucking, he came up higher and just lunged at it again.
He was eating it like a, like a fucking Komodo Dragon, you know,
they just sorta fucking lunge at something and just,
just saw and rip away as he was a fucking animal and every,
he would lunge at this thing. It was, I could not look at him and I was crying,
laughing of course by three bites.
He looked over and he caught me looking at him laughing and then I looked at
Nate and I pointed at the menu like I was laughing like, oh my God,
they have chicken fingers. Isn't that hilarious?
Like I was trying to somehow get away from it, but long story short,
the grilled cheese was all right. The fucking wings were horrific.
Even when they were actually heated up. They clearly made them hours ago,
the way they came over fucking ice cold.
And then they brought me some hot ones like three seconds later.
And so the lady comes over and she picks up our check.
She walks over the register in the,
and in that short amount of time she already forgot where we were sitting.
And then when she came back, you know, Nate picked up the check,
she gave it back to me. It was just was fucking horrific man.
Um,
but other than that, they told the beach was beautiful. We did a show that,
and I always would be like, what are you shitting on? Fuck it. They taught her,
fuck, we can't because that's what I saw. I didn't know where to go. So anyways,
I um, I played the, uh,
I want to say PBT theater cause where I'm from, that's how you say Peabody,
the Peabody theater. It's like when you need, when you're in New York,
it's Carnegie Hall and when you're in Pittsburgh, it's Carnegie. All right.
When you're in Massachusetts, it's,
it's Peabody and everywhere else it's Peabody.
So we played the Peabody theater. I had a great time,
did an hour and 20 minutes, you know, all new shit,
shit that got left off of other hours. Just had a great fucking time.
The crowd was awesome, got a bunch of heckles, but they were all great. I liked,
I liked that shit. I don't mind when people yell out.
Um,
you know, to a point I don't mind it.
And I had a good time and I made a point of saying that,
cause sometimes people in the crowd was sorry for all the fucking heckles.
I enjoy it. I don't mind a lively drunk ass crowd. I'm a fucking drunk.
Okay. And now that I've shit on everybody,
you know that I met basically in a 12 hour period in Daytona.
Um,
let's talk about the, uh, we went to the race the next day and by the way,
thank you to everybody who came out to the show.
I mean it was such a big fucking event the next day.
I mean they should have been three people in the crowd.
So the fact that it was sold out was fucking amazing. So thank you to everybody.
I will definitely be back. Um,
but I will not be eating at that fucking place with the cars that are side in
half.
Um,
so anyways, plowing ahead here. So the next day we go to the race and uh,
we weren't really thinking that there's going to be 250,000 fucking people.
That's like two and a half rose bowls all descending on the same fucking the
same place. So all the locals are going like, Oh man,
I'm just staying in tomorrow. That's gonna be a shit show, blah blah blah,
blah blah. And when I had driven from the airport, you know, when you get off,
what's so fucking cool when you get off at the airport,
you can actually hear them racing. You know, I think there was a truck racist,
some shit like that. I keep the land, you know,
I didn't get into like fucking one in the morning at midnight actually.
So the race was already overboard. Nick got there and you could hear him racing.
You pull out, you can see the fucking day,
Tony International fucking speedway, which is amazing, right? Legendary place.
And as you drive and buy this,
all these fucking people in RVs and all that hanging out,
wait to go on the race and do these people do not fuck around
the way they were doing it up.
Like it's the way I wish we did it at the Rose Bowl.
Like I've never seen so many like,
okay,
I mean legit like you could,
you could like a rock star could tour in some of these fucking mobile homes,
um, in the setups that they had and the fucking flat screen TVs,
you know,
on the outside with the generator and they had smokers going and everybody just
having a great fucking time waiting for this race to happen.
And evidently people who park on the infield can get there like something like a
week or 10 days. They've just been in there
as these guys are fucking driving around. Um, the track, you know,
getting ready to go to the race and all that, you know,
testing out their cars and shit. Um,
qualifying for pole position or whatever the fuck it is that they're doing.
These people are sitting there like to me though,
that's that those a die hard fans, right?
So we ended up calling a fucking Uber, um,
the venue the night before hooked us up with this guy, this driver. And um,
he knew all these back ways to get there, which was a godsend.
And he got us like right to where it says, um,
Daytona International speedway and uh,
Nate Barr got C's like hooked up with some of those NASCAR guys and they came by
about 20 minutes later,
picked us up in this little golf cart and just gave us the,
the total VIP treatment.
And this is the one thing I will say about NASCAR versus the NFL is the level of
fan access to all these different do you can,
you could walk right down onto pit row.
We were sitting on the track before the race,
like a couple hours before the race. They let you go up there.
Everybody was like taking pictures at the finish line. And um,
one thing I couldn't believe was how fucking small it is as far as the width of
it. It's like these people will go three side-by-side, 200 miles an hour.
They were out of their minds. Um, you got to be right down there on pit row.
Um, I met Mario Andretti, got to shake his hand and uh,
that was another thing too, like the,
just the array of like famous people that were there.
I guess the appeal of NASCAR was fucking nuts. Like you'd see Mario Andretti,
which makes sense. Race car driver. I saw Gronkowski
um, guy fee airy. Uh,
who else? There was some fucking model, this gorgeous model there.
Kiano Reeves, LaDainian Tom Wilson. It was just fucked.
It was like all over the fucking map and you'd see like, oh that guy,
he's the senator of fucking, you know, whatever, South Carolina.
Um,
we got to go in and you know,
we got to sit in on like the drivers meeting and all of that,
which is really fucking interesting.
I thought it was just going to be the drivers and like four of us,
but it was this giant fucking room where they let this whole crowd go into is
just sitting there talking to the drivers going, all right. Uh, you know,
it's been a lot of, uh,
trying to bump guys off the track into the fucking stands.
You gotta stop doing that. I mean, I don't know what,
I didn't even know what they was saying.
I was kind of sitting behind the guy so I couldn't quite hear him. But, um,
I mean, I can't imagine going into like a fucking any NFL game,
but he got to hear the referees talking to the head coaches before the game.
You know, the NFL is like the God Damn CIA.
You can't get anywhere near anything. So, um, we ended up, uh,
watching the race from the infield and uh,
you know, I knew some people there. So you, at one point we were with, um,
the people from Cisco brewery down on Nantucket. If you ever go to Nantucket,
um, crazy good beer. And then they got the, this vodka,
they had like this blueberry vodka and cranberry vodka that you're fucking
ladies gonna love.
And, um,
we hung with them for awhile and then we also were at this other fucking place
in, Ah, our view was absolutely insane. It was a bunch of fucking,
I dunno, crashes and cautions. It's the fucking race took forever. But, um,
I dunno. I can't, I still can't believe that I got to go, go to it.
But thank you to everybody at NASCAR for hooking us up.
And, um,
I'm trying to remember who the fuck one was at. Kyle Bush cow Bush one. Right.
I went there and I just routed for fucking Dale Earnhardt jr Jr. You know,
it's been so long since I've watched NASCAR. I'm like,
is Jeff Gordon still racing? It's like, Nah, he's retired.
Like everybody I knew was gone. Like I,
I watched it big time in the early fucking eighties, late seventies,
early eighties when it was like Bobby Alanson, Cale Yarborough,
Harry Gant, Richard Petty. I saw him when like his last Daytona 500.
I'm like 81 or something, um, than Cale Yarborough won two years in a row.
Then it was a bill Elliot era. And, um, I don't know. Somewhere around there,
I was trying to get through college and I started doing standup and I kind of
lost touch with it, but I, I still paid attention, um, right through, uh,
the Dale Earnhardt years and, uh, I dunno, I haven't watched it in a minute,
but it's fucking amazing dude. The whole thing.
It was just such an amazing experience and I'm a, I don't know,
maybe I'll go to Talladega. Who knows? I think that one's in May. We'll see.
But the big thing I was excited about was the fact that, uh,
I was able to do like an hour and 20 minutes and not bore people shit that
they'd already heard before. So, um, you know,
that's like the big fear when you go back out on the road after you had a
special commodities, you're like, all right,
how do I fucking do a bunch of new shit without fucking these people over?
Sorry, I'm adjusting the microphone here without fucking these people over. Um,
and I'm still thinking that I was funny,
especially after going on after Nate Barr. Gutsy.
Who by the way is I'm one of like six people that got half hours on a,
on Netflix. I think Netflix is trying to do like the HBO one night stands.
So he was running his ready to tape special in front of me and that guy's one of
the best joke writers I know and he fucking murdered.
So I was relieved that I was able to, uh,
go on after him and have a good time. So anyways, is it time? Yeah.
How about a little bit of advertising here? Everybody? All right. Where are we?
Okay.
Wandering the fuck is this stuff. Never heard of this one.
Wondery um, here's a podcast you should listen to. Wait a minute,
I'm somebody else's podcast is advertising on my podcast. Yeah.
Don't listen to my podcast. Listen to this one. All right. What?
I remember this shit. This one's actually sounded cool. All right. Uh, secrets,
crimes and audio tape. It's a podcast that has a different story every week.
Uh, this week story is called, this is not a Banksy.
It's about a guy who wakes up in the morning and realizes Banksy drew on his
ass. Who the fuck is Banksy?
He gets it tattooed and now people want to collect his ass.
It doesn't go well. It was, it has high production values.
It's funny. And Mario Lopez is the guest star. Go listen to it. All right.
This is why I liked that podcast is because it sounds different and it also,
the copy was nice and short. Is Banksy? Uh, he's an, he's an artist, right?
I only know this because Nia is into all that shit. Let me,
let me look this fucking up.
So he drew on somebody's ass and then he had a tattooed
and now what?
Who the fuck is Banksy? Banksy is an anonymous English-based graffiti artists,
political activists and film director. Weave is anonymous.
How come they know who he is? Um, have on verified identity. Oh,
there you go. There's satirically street art and subversive.
Well then how the fuck did this guy know Banksy drew on his ass?
Okay,
man, he's got great work.
I want to judge them on the two that are on his Wikipedia page. Oh,
these are amazing. What a talented son of a bitch. He must be really shy.
Um,
so he does this in England. What if it's one of his,
somebody from the royal family. And the reason why they don't say it is because,
you know, graffiti is looked down upon by the, uh, the aristocrats, you know,
stop drawing on our buildings. Um, maybe that's who it is.
So I guess he drew on somebody's ass.
Okay.
Somebody who knows him well. Well, I'm surprised the, uh,
the Illuminati doesn't kidnap that dude and his ass and it goes,
tell me who the fuck Banksy is.
Tell me who Banksy is or I'll fucking scalp your ass and that painting and then
your ass won't work and it won't be worth shit. How about that? No Pun intended.
All right. Dollar Shave club, everybody.
There's no reason to use a cheap disposable razor or pay a ridiculously high
price for some gimmicky thing that's got a laser pointer with 17 blades.
Make the smarter choice and Join Dollar Shave Club before dollar shave club.
It was either save money and get a painful shade from a disposable razor like
the ones they did give away free at the gym,
which felt like shaving with a piece of fucking glass or pay a fortune for the
latest gimmicky shave breakthrough you don't need.
Like a laser chin detector is 17 more blades. Assam Shit.
Dollar Shave Club is the best of both worlds.
Eight premium shape at a disposable price. Get a close shave.
I get a close, smooth shave every time.
And you can't beat the convenience or the price of the club if you haven't tried
dollar shave club yet, you're missing out.
It's an amazing shape and an affordable price.
There's no smarter choice in the market.
And right now they're giving away a one month trial for any of their raises for
a dollar with free shipping free. Um, and after that,
it's just a few bucks a month. There's no longterm commitments, no hidden fees.
You can cancel whenever you want.
Get your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash bird that's dollar shave
club.com/bar oh look who's back everybody. It's my favorite.
It's old zip.
[inaudible]
right? Are you hiring well? Are Ya?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place and it's not enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect car,
you need to post your job on all the top job sites and God damn it.
Now you can with ziprecruiter.com you can post your job at 2100 plus job sites,
including social media networks like Facebook or the Twitter,
all with a single click. Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll in to all zip,
easy to use interface, no juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates, rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why
Zip Karuna has been used by fortune 100 companies and thousands of small and
medium sized businesses.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com bar. That's ziprecruiter.com/bear one more time.
Try It for free. Go to a zip
pro.com/bar all right, is this the last one? Lastly,
but not leastly up stamps.com they're always the headliner. You know,
I used to have [inaudible] dot com anytime I have a host,
a poster I need to mail out,
you know I'm going to wear myself out meeting the meeting.
The people out there with their bad tattoos and their sweaty hands,
postage rates can have gone up again.
That means trips to the post office are an even bigger hassle, man,
it's so crowded, but thanks to stamps.com you don't gotta worry about that Shit.
That's for the fucking peons. Not You. You better than that,
right? You're in a sweet eating,
a little surf and turf next to the fucking orange cont.
Just use stamps.com to automatically calculate and print the correct amount of
postage for every letter or package you sent.
stamps.com brings all the surfaces of the US Postal Service right to your
fingertips. They'll send you a digital scale. Oh my God, it's beautiful.
Automatically calculate exact postage stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class that mail based on your needs.
They give you postage discounts and that you can't get it to a post office,
including 3 cents off every first class stamp. Right now, use my code burp.
You are for this special offer,
four week trial that includes postage and a digital scale at scale. Sorry,
go to stance.com. Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburthatstampsdotcomentertuberandsignuptodaywithstamps.com
you'll never a with stamps.com you'll never have to go to the post office again
or listen to me read out loud again during this fucking podcast. All right,
let me,
let me a select all of this and then delete it so I can get to the fucking
questions for this week. Dollar Shave Club, which was the first one.
The first one was the, uh, the Banksy.
Banksy fucking tattooed my ass. Um, all right.
Oh by the way, everybody, uh, I mentioned lately that uh, I'm,
I'm going to be certain posts, some videos up to my youtube, my youtube page.
Uh, I'm going to a bunch of videos from the Daytona 500. I'm going to have, um,
at www.youtube.com/users/monday morning podcast.
I'm going to give the fucking video to my guy this week.
He's going to edit it and get the shit up there. Okay. I'll,
I'll tweet about it when it gets up there. All right, so speaking of stamps,
I bought some stamps today.
I did not use stamps.com I was driving from a Daytona beach up here to
Gainesville. And rather than going like the highway way, I,
I took the longer route cause I want to see some shit. Right?
Like going by this fucking, my brother told me it's called folk art.
I guess I drove by this woman's house. So this guy's house.
Otherwise I thought it was a woman,
but you don't have like a giant tyrannosaurus rex, a fucking bull,
like kicking his legs up. Like all these
things that you can put on your fucking lawn, I guess.
I don't know what all this crazy stuff that, you know,
you don't see that when you take 75 north,
it's just going to be a bunch of Arby's. We got the meats.
It's going to be the same fucking 10 chains and a god Damn Walmart.
I've seen that a zillion times, but if he, if he take the old school, the,
the fucking route 66 Jack Kerouac ways, it takes longer,
but you see a bunch of cool shit. So I was fucking driving along there and uh,
I came upon a post office and Lo and behold, I had a,
I had a built that I need to pay and I didn't have a fucking stamp.
So I fucking Poland and the locals that are in there and I'm listening to this
guy tell this fucking hilarious story. Um, first of all,
I love the pace of it too.
I love the pace of a small town where I don't give a shit that this guy's
telling his story. He's such a fucking character. I'm enjoying it.
I'm already second in line cause there's nobody fucking there. Right.
And he's telling his story about how somebody cut him off.
Yeah.
You know,
and he's not driving too fast so than the woman behind the counter then tells
her story about how she was doing 15,
someone pulled out in front of her and her son and his son blew the horn and
when they pulled up next to him at a red light,
the guy fucking had had a pistol and he fucking just brought it up looking at
him like, you know, pointing at the ceiling of his car.
He just sort of brought it up like that. And then the guy's like,
egos can't do that. Can't do that.
I write that such a terrorist act that's branded should brandishing a weapon.
And you start talking about brandishing a weapon. You can't do that.
That'll make somebody want to, uh, you know,
do some sort of self defense is what's up. It was saying, and I was just like,
this is fucking crazy out here. But actually I think that they said that, that,
that happened up in a Charlotte or something like that.
I guess the road rage is off the fucking chains. It's in Charlotte,
North Carolina. That's what I love about a small town.
I never would have heard that, you know,
just fucking guy with his white uncle Jesse Beard, tell a story,
brandishing a weapon.
And I was just sitting there totally not even given a fuck that I was standing
in line at the post office,
completely enjoying this story and praying to God that this guy then took out
his weapon cause I wanted, I wanted to see where this was going to go next.
But you know, they didn't say anything like,
oh I should've got his license plate and Blah Blah Blah Blah Blah. Um,
I dunno think that's why I stay off the 75 north.
Cause I never would have heard that. You know, if I'd stayed on the 75 north,
I would have heard, you know, uh, can I get the fucking a,
can I get a double cheeseburger with the bucket liberal blue?
I don't wanna hear that shit. Oh,
I know a lot of you guys are expecting me to talk about the Oscars,
but I didn't watch them. Okay. I don't watch award shows unless I'm home.
If I'm home, then, uh,
my wife's watching them and then I watch it with her because I like making fun
of them while she watches them cause it makes her mad. She doesn't get mad mad,
but she gets like upset. But uh, I heard about the, the big,
the big fucking thing there in the end where a Warren Beatty came out and he's
like a little wet are for the best picture.
2017 goes though La la land.
And evidently the poor people from la La land went up.
There were two speeches in before they realized that it was actually going to
moonlight, starring Civil Sam Shepard and Bruce Willis, I believe.
Um, I dunno what the fuck happened.
All I know is once I heard that that happened, I didn't want to watch it.
You know, I don't,
I don't like watching people like that level of fucking awkwardness, you know?
Okay.
I just seen Warren Beatty be that fucking old.
I just realized his last fucking name was what that fucking robot was saying on
close, not close encounters. What was that? What does that stupid fucking shit?
Buck Rogers where they had that little stupid fucking robot go. Yeah.
BDB BDB does he say baby baby, baby baby.
There was a stupid, like somebody came up,
but somebody sitting in a fucking writers room and they're like, all right,
star wars is all the rage. We gotta somehow make money off this.
How are we going to do buck Rogers? That doesn't seem that bad.
I mean it was around before star wars and one of the things we got to have like
an r two d two and a c three Po and the network's like, well,
we're not fucking ironman to actors. It's gonna be too expensive.
Combined both characters and stick a fucking midget and that goddamn suit.
All right. Sorry. All right, we'll see three pos.
Kind of a fucking smart cut with an English accent.
I would just have this thing be a moron. It just, yeah, it has a catch phrase.
I don't know. What's the catch? What you fucking come up with it.
And the writers are probably so pissed. All right,
let's just come up with the dumbest shit we can possibly say and see what this
fucking industry person says. I, he is a little fucking,
he looks like a little kid, George Washington,
but he's painted all silver and he's made out of metal. And before he talks,
he walks around, he goes, yeah,
baby, baby, baby, baby.
You know, and then they just sat there and they kept the fucking straight face.
And that's one of those moments in life, you know,
when you throw it on the table, you know, you're looking at that person,
they looking at you and it becomes one of those moments where whoever talks
first loses and you just fucking wait it out. And then the fucking person goes,
ah, yeah, go with that. And they're like, great, awesome.
Well let's go do some cocaine. It's not fucking addicting, right?
It's fucking the late seventies. Um, yeah. So I didn't, I didn't see, uh,
I didn't see any of it.
Sorry. I know I got a bunch of tweets.
Can't wait to hear your take on the Oscars. I did not see what I did see.
Was that the fucking Boston Bruins one again? One again,
it all my fucking wine in about wine and about, uh, you know,
them getting rid of clothed Julian. Uh, according to Bob Beers,
the Bruins are playing much looser and more confident under Bush. Bruce Cassidy,
sorry, should I say Bush? Bruce Cassidy. Um, so with the new man on the bench,
the Boston Bruins look like a new team.
The bees are and one since Bruce Cassidy took over as interim coach averaging
four goals per game while scoring the first and six of those contests,
they exploded for six goals and Sundays matinee went over the stars.
But the stars suck this year and a 98.5, this sports hub,
Bruins analyst Bob Beers says he's seen a much looser and more confident team.
Uh, take the ice since Cassidy took over for Clo Julian,
they have a little more leash and a little more freedom to make some plays down
to the point where they're being reckless or carried away,
leaving themselves exposed. At the other end,
but they're encouraged to play more offensively. Um,
I gotta tell you, man, they've been playing great, so I don't know what it is.
So, you know, I guess I was wrong. I still think Khloe,
Julian's a fucking great coach. What are you gonna do? Maybe.
Maybe everybody needed to change, you know, maybe that's what it is.
Like you stay with the same person for awhile. He just gets sick of them.
You know? And this is like the new girlfriend. You're all excited.
You can go all the old places, but it's new for the both of you to go there.
I don't know. All I know is it's fucking working.
And I absolutely loved,
loved the Boston Celtics not making a move before the trade deadline.
I think that was fucking genius. It was.
It would have been so fucking stupid to give up draft picks and in some players
that we had, you know,
that they were gonna want like Marcus smart and fucking Jae Crowder and a bunch
of draft picks.
At the very least we were going to have to fucking give up that to bring in who?
Carmelo Anthony.
You know
who's, who's going to,
he's going to tell fucking everybody to clear out and then not get back on d.
You don't need that shit.
And even if he got us past the Cavaliers when nobody's beaten the fucking
warriors this year, or we're certainly not.
You give up all of that shit to do what?
Come in second place instead of fourth. Who gives a fuck?
Who gives a fuck? This is the Boston Celtics.
We got to win another championship.
The Lakers are lying about the amount of fucking champions championships they
have. They padded their resume with one. We need to win another one.
Put a little distance between them and I think this fucking move right here.
Being patient enough to just say, no, we're staying in the goddamn course.
We've got all these draft picks. You know? Who knows?
Maybe that kid from Duke comes out a Tatum,
maybe he's one and done. Who knows? You know they got that.
Who's that other kid that some kid on Kansas,
I guess he's like a point guard or something like that.
I don't know what the fuck we need. I don't know shit about basketball,
but I love not giving into the stupid pressure that you know you're supposed to
make a move, you know that'll make you better in the short run,
but fuck you. Fuck over all the work you've been doing over the last three,
four years. So Danny, age, Danny Age. Love it.
Absolutely love it. All right, let's do some reads for this week because
I'm actually going to drive down to Tampa tonight and I'm going to go, uh,
I'm going to go to the fucking Tampa Bay lightning versus the fucking auto with
senators game tonight. Palm never been to a game. Then we'll see how it is.
All right, four reads. All right. This is what I got here. Oh,
four reads was the advertising. It's not for questions. Let me get rid of that.
Okay. Boyfriend birthday gift. Hey there,
Billy birthday boy, my boyfriend,
my man recently celebrated a birthday and I contemplated for weeks what I would
get them after listening to many podcasts episode,
I picked up on your advice to freshly single men. Uh,
get yourself all the sports packages.
I took all Billy boys advice and bought my guy a subscription for NHL TV.
All these shit. You're a fucking angel for the remainder of the hockey season.
Parenthesis go pens. That's great too. So he and his and his team is a,
a contender,
so it'll be fun to watch and NFL Sunday ticket for the upcoming football season.
He's beyond thrilled. Of course he is.
Thanks for the laughs and most importantly, thanks for the birthday suggestion.
Alright ladies, did you hear that?
You know what's great about all of that shit is it's so fucking easy to do.
That's one phone call. You don't have to go out and go shop.
You don't have to go get something fucking engraved. It's perfect.
And if anybody wants to outdo this woman,
you know what you do is you get them the perfect chair to sit there and watch,
you know.
And then what you do is you get life insurance and as he slowly eats and drinks
himself to death watch and all these sports, you know,
you're going to win either way.
Either he's going to be around and he's going to be this big lovable fucking,
you know,
grizzly bear over there watching his games or he's going to fucking die and
you're going to get paid. You know, there you go. Good for you.
That's a, that's a great gift. I would love that. I would that,
I would be thrilled with that gift. Alright. Who versus whom?
Ah, a little aristocrat fucking compensation here. Uh, the actual rule,
I always get these confused and I love that you guys are going to fucking help
me out here. Cause I actually used spoon the other day.
Somebody told me that when you use who is,
is if you could substitute it with he or she. But if you're talking about uh,
they are us or a Soliloquy, then you use home. I don't know.
Anyways, he said the actual rule to you is who? With the subject in whom?
Oh, the actual rule is to use who with the subject. In whom?
With the object. So it's the subject like a person.
No, I don't. I, I'll never get this done.
Okay.
It's like live versus lay.
The baby on the bed lies down,
but when you put the baby on the bed, the baby is laid down.
[inaudible]
all right. Like how was that supposed to help me? All right,
let's try and figure out the subject of the object. Oh my God.
I'm going to start fucking hyperventilating. This takes me to high school.
Okay.
They call on you like, I don't know. I don't know.
Just give me a fucking zero.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. Are We fucking tied? You got to call on me.
I don't know the answer before you figure out you need to call on somebody else.
Quarterback keeps throwing to somebody to keep dropping the ball. They they,
they go to somebody else. Fucking idiot. Punt. All right.
The baby on the bed lies down. All right,
so the baby is, the subject is the bed, the object,
but when you put the baby on the bed, that's an object. The baby's laid down.
All right, well what the fuck?
Who laid the baby down versus Billy boo?
Blue balls laid home down. All right, I got to slow down.
Who laid the baby down?
Okay.
Who laid the baby down? You did.
You did shoot that boys and Arrow through my, huh? Shoot.
That boy is narrow. Thank you. Good night. Took me back.
I always sing that song to Nia and I always say,
whoever sinks that fucking song,
you know that they close with it and then that's how they end that song.
That's how they ended. They go shoot that poison Arrow to buy. Ah,
shoot that poison arrow. Thank you. Good night. Yeah, the surprise ending.
Oh, I thought you gotta go through my heart again, but you didn't. All right,
so who laid the baby down? All right.
Okay.
Versus Billy balls laid whom down.
Who laid the baby? Okay, so if I went like,
yeah,
who drank all his fucking beer?
Billy blue balls.
Okay,
well it's who drank all the beer. I can't fucking do it.
[inaudible]
who drank all this beer? How can I keep plug that in.
All right, well somebody says something about a baby. I have a baby my life,
so I have a chance I can at least get that one right. Oh,
Jesus sent right back down to the minors. Yeah. Once again,
he grounds into an inning ending. Double play. Fucking kill that goddamn dream.
I, well I don't understand. I just don't fucking get,
this has been explained to me. 50 million.
I never understood how fucking planes flew.
And then I got my pilots license and they were able to fucking explain it to me.
Who laid the baby down
versus Billy blue balls laid whom down.
All right,
so I'm the subject in the first one and then then what?
The baby becomes an object. Like are you talking shit about my kid here?
Billy blue bluebells laid home.
The actual rule is to use who with the subject and who with the object.
So I'm more important than my kids. So I'm the object here is that I'm done.
I'm the subject, but then a,
that doesn't mean it can he sense because a king has subjects and they have to
do whatever the fuck they, he tells them. I'll tell you right now, I don't know.
I don't feel any closer to the finish line than I was Jesus.
The amount of empathy that I have for all the fucking teachers in my life,
that this is the fucking putty. They're trying to mold into something.
All right.
You know it's great for Great Barrier Reef. For Fuck's sakes. Bill.
Stop saying the Great Barrier Reef is dying.
Get your pasty white ranger rs down here.
Get in the water and have a look for it. It's not dying. Yeah, it is. You can't,
what are you assigned to? I'm going by what the fucking scientists are saying.
And I wanted to go fucking a snorkeling over there. He said,
you better do it now cause they're not gonna let people go there much longer.
And if you don't know what a ranger is that we all C's call red headed.
Fuck's like you a ranger being short for a rang of tank.
Oh, I guess, isn't that cute? Well, you know what?
Maybe you can say that to me next time he come down there and do a fucking show.
All right. Why don't you do that? I don't give a fuck. You think I give a fuck?
But what some con who at the bottom of the fucking world,
we're like three quarters of your goddamn country. You can't even go to
the entire middle of that fucking content is you continent.
You can't even live there.
Okay.
What else do you do on Australia Day?
Do you drive around and your poor excuse for a fucking El Camino?
Um, anyways. Oh, that's, yeah, he's one of those fucking guys. Ah,
that's fine. It's still fucking there. You know,
I'm going to look this shit up right now. All right, great. Barrier Reef.
Let me see what I get and let me guess because it doesn't agree with you then
it's going to be fake news. Great Barrier Reef dead. Uh,
the Great Barrier Reef is not actually dead. CNN dramatic. Oh, go.
What about dying? Let me see. Dying. Die Ying. Let me see. Dying.
Uh, corals are dying on the great barrier.
Reef scientists have discovered an unprecedented die off of the,
in the world's largest reef. The Great Barrier Reef. Prom. Yeah, there you go.
Right there. Okay, great. Barrier Reef not dying. Australia insists.
Oh, I get it. This is your big tourist attraction. This is your Ferris wheel.
So you want people to keep flying down there so they can jump on the water with
a bunch of great white sharks because there's nothing to see on land down there.
Cause three quarters of your fucking country is unlivable and God knows if you
go out there, it's so fucking unlived.
That's why are snakes and everything down there.
It's so fucking poisonous because it's such a lack of food
that a snake, if it just grazes somebody, they gotta make it count.
Cause God knows they're not gonna see anything edible for fucking weeks.
Australia insists that it's not fucking dying. I love it. Okay,
well that's fucking credible. That's how you make all your money.
All those fucking cons going down there and this scuba gear because they learned
how to hold their breath and breathe under water.
And a fucking swimming pool and they got themselves a little scuba card and now
they're going to go into God's swimming pool. A fucking ocean. All right.
That's got all this shit that can kill on that gun. That's what it is. Okay.
Again, I'm sorry.
I was fucking with the tourist attraction that that'd be like you guys down
there saying that he can't go up into the armor, the Statue of Liberty anymore.
It's going to snap off.
Um,
it is dying. You're stupid. Fuck. All right. All right.
Anyways, I absolutely believe that it is.
Why wouldn't it be all this shit that we're doing?
Why would everything else is fucking dying?
Everything else is completely fucked, but that isn't a, maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe I'm wrong. Let me, you know what? I actually, I looked it up.
Let me look up, not dying. Let's see what this said. Great Barrier Reef.
But if this is all from fucking Australia, I'm not buying it.
Great Barrier Reef not in danger can be a big picture of fucking Trump.
Scuba diving. The Great Barrier Reef, not quote,
endanger tourism and mining groups have welcomed a whatever recommendation that
the great barrier reef be left off the world. Heritage in danger. Yeah. Touring,
tourism, mining. These people all make money off it.
Um,
should the great B barrier reef be listed as in danger.
UNESCO. Great Barrier Reef is not endangered but needs care.
You and Asperger experts say great barrier reef now. Yeah,
this is all because you're not making money off of it.
Great Barrier Reef Outlook. Poor but not in danger.
This is like what you guys are doing with the Great Barrier Reef now is what we
do with our food supply.
You know, it's not the best for you, but it doesn't necessarily cause cancer.
Um, and you know what buddy? I hope you right. I hope you're right.
I hope it isn't,
but I know God good and God damn well that you're not a fucking scientist.
I know I'm not a scientist and I know that scientists say that is fucking dying,
but anybody for what I just did,
my research for 30 seconds was anybody that makes money off of it.
Say it says that it isn't. So I don't know. Can I, can you,
if you can write me back with a fucking scientists or some sort of fucking group
of them that don't make money off it or not getting paid to say that it's
fucking dying. Uh, it's not dying then, then I'll believe it. Okay.
So what a mom. I'm still fucking open-minded. Um, all right.
Obama News, censorship. Uh, hey Mr Bill,
um, Bill Burr.
I have listened to the past couple of podcasts where some of your listeners have
messaged in about Obama's.
Suppose it's censoring of news media and after a bit of further research,
it seems like they're most likely inaccurate or just wrong.
Now let me ask you this sir, cause I looked it up. Okay.
If what I could tell it was accurate,
but what I'm guessing is you're an Obama fan,
so now you're going to tell me this is fake news.
Now you just saw where I was able to look up shit where it said it was dying and
then the isn't dying and it's just all what you choose to believe, right? Uh,
while the bill is real,
the conclusion that it would cause the shutdown and silencing of dissenting
opinions seems an incorrect,
it's supposed to find the identity when foreign countries are involved in
spreading propaganda to allow us news sites to know where information is coming
from. I have a liberal bias and am probably overlooking some things. Oh,
there you go. This guy's an adult. Okay. You know what,
I take back everything I said,
but it seems like that the bill is not nearly as bad as certain sites are making
out to be,
which I would agree with cause that that's going to be the Fox News people.
Thanks for the podcast and the latest special. Um,
this is what I would guess which is a obviously a total guest cause I'm a
fucking moron. Um,
I'm guessing it's not as bad as people on the right are saying it is,
but I'm definitely of the belief that there's always that wiggle room in there
that, you know, is, is there preventing something, you know,
that everybody wants to be prevented, which would be, uh,
propaganda from our fucking enemies,
which actually don't even think is that bad.
I'm not against hearing their take on things. Um,
but it would also allow them, it's Kinda like, you know,
after nine 11 where it was just like, we need to listen.
We need to be able to listen in on people's phone conversations.
But if you're not doing anything wrong, you know, a, it's then a fucking love.
You know, it's,
this is just for terrorist and then it just becomes a way for them to spy on you
even more.
And then years later you see that whole fucking Snowden thing and he's taken off
basically saying, I'm not going to help you guys build this thing.
The greatest nerd of all time is that snowed guy. You know,
I suppose those other fucking pussies who just keep fucking, you know,
I've always said it, you know, total psychos,
like a complete psycho has no fucking power. You know, without nerds,
nerds give them the ability to be as cycle on a psycho,
on a fucking global level. Okay.
Is his nuts as Trump is his nuts as fucking Hillary is nuts as fucking Bush.
It's not just all these fucking loaded techs are then that shit without nerds
creating the technology for them to, uh, you know,
go psycho on a global fucking level.
You mean if it wasn't for fucking nerds and we'd still be attacking each other
with sticks, you know, I, I couldn't figure out how to make a gun.
All right, last my 401k. Hey Bill. Uh,
well to cut to the chase, I'm 51 years old.
Divorced son is in jail for hitting his mother who was a lunatic. Jesus Christ.
And I received a $49,000 settlement and blew it all on the California lottery.
This can't be real. I really feel like throwing in the towel.
Can you tell me what you would do if you were in my awful shoes?
All right. If this is even remotely real,
um,
let's see. This probably fake, but whatever I can,
but other people have completely fucked up their lives. So I'll,
I'll talk to them. And you, sir, if you're actually telling the truth, um,
the biggest thing you got going for yourself is you know that you're a moron in
you fucked up your life.
So I would sit down and I would look at the decisions that I've made,
figured out why I made those fucking decisions.
I refuse to believe that you're dumb enough to get $49,000 and spend all of it
on the California lottery. I would think that some of it went to bear.
Some of them. It went to Wade. Come on, somebody had 49,000 bucks.
You can get yourself a new truck. Come on. Come on.
I don't know.
Can you tell me what you would do if you were in my office shoes? Uh,
I would get a fucking job. First of all, I would stay away from, um,
that stay away from your ex wife. You son's in jail for hitting your mother.
So that would mean he's of age. Um,
so you're not paying any child support. So maybe there's some alimony.
Um,
I dunno, I try to teach my son not to hit my mother. I mean,
I'm [inaudible] not to hit his mother.
I don't know dude. You, you got you,
you got water coming in from all sides here. I don't know what to tell you.
Um,
if you get money, I would save it rather than gamble it away.
And uh, but you're only 51 years old, dude. This is what I would do.
I would say I would start P90x get a little bit,
it's fucking self esteem and have a little more belief in yourself that you can
make it other than trying to do a fucking nine zillion to one shot,
which you tried to cut down to a 49,000 to 49,000 shots at a billion to one.
Um, yeah, dude, I don't know what to tell you, man.
I think you're going to be fine. You 51 years old, you know, you still got,
you still got some years ahead of you, but I would just, uh,
I wouldn't throw my fucking money away like that. I mean,
I don't know how to give you advice if you blew all your money on lottery
tickets. Uh, but I don't want you to throw in the towel.
You know what I would do? I would write a fucking book, stare into it.
You know, like if it's the comic's comic, you might be the losers loser.
Write a fucking book about it,
you know?
Well, make some youtube videos and just tell your fucking story.
Get some advertising right? Maybe you can make a little bit of money that way.
Shit, it's easy to make 49,000 bucks off the fucking Internet.
There's enough people that people love, people failing you,
who the fuck's failed more than you turn it around.
Turn that failing into a fucking positive. Tell you fucking story.
Start going around to schools telling people what not to do.
I don't know what you should do, but don't do what I did. Right.
That's a country lyrics. They always, they're always doing that shit.
Like I was thinking on the drive over here talking about this person in front of
me was driving so slow is like Jesus Christ,
you've got all the time in the world. I'm like,
that's such like a country lyric that they would flip around.
You know,
I've got all the time in the world than I don't want to go on live in. You know,
you see it's a juxtaposition there. You know what I mean?
It's like I got all this time my hands,
but I don't want any time cause I'm a mom.
My woman left me or something like that. Right. It's like,
wait up fucking a bull wants to fuck a cow but ain't going on around but a pig.
You know what I mean? It's one of those types of things.
I would just steer into it sir.
I would turn it into entertaining stories that somehow tell them,
but I'm also a comedian. That's what the fuck I would do.
Other than that I would stay away from your ex wife and um,
I dunno, I dunno what to do with you son. Try to set a better example
by not blowing all your money on lottery tickets. Maybe that's,
that's the thing. I don't know. Sorry. You were in that situation.
If you actually are all right. Text sent to the wrong person at work. Oh Jesus.
This is never good. Uh, dear Billy Graham cracker tits.
Um, I never thought I'd be in a situation where I needed to write into you like
this, but here I am in a pinch. For the last couple of years,
certain people at my work have been getting very relaxed with their work ethic
and punctuality.
So much so that another coworker and I have written an album of songs about its
absurdity.
Okay.
Since our office is,
well maybe you can write a song about the guy who just wrote in above me,
you know,
you guys, you know, then you go on American idol. I don't know. Anyways,
since ours is an office of about 10 people,
everybody's job directly relates to everyone else's and it puts extra strain on
the rest of us. Recently, two of the worst defenders, both ladies,
not that it matters, I'm have actually, but I mentioned it, uh,
have actually gotten promotions for some reason. With that said this morning,
I noticed one of the ladies accomplished a quote task in our project manager.
Yeah.
Uh, to bring food to an office, potluck, lunch
being the snarky asshole I am.
I took a screenshot to send to my likeminded coworker with the techs,
quote, think, and then the person's name is going a little overboard here.
Somehow she only creates to do, she can get done,
can't get shit done for work, but for food, the bitches all over it.
When I didn't hear back from after 10 minutes, I felt this first wave of panic.
I knew it immediately. The techs had been sent to the lady. Yeah.
Cause what happens is you're thinking about that person and you're thinking
about their name and you, Oh my God, we've all done this completely flustered.
I sent a flurry of apology texts, but she didn't respond.
Okay.
All this was happening around eight 30 which is when people are supposed to
arrive.
This work or usually shows up around nine 45 or 10 but that's beside the point.
What can you unsend the text? I Dunno.
Just some nerd know how to do that. Anyways, after I didn't hear from her,
I checked the calendar and saw that she was on vacation for the next 10 days.
Oh No. But I know she got the text and now I'm worried about what she thinks and
whether it's going to be weird in the office. What do I do?
She's not a bad person. And when you called her a bitch too,
and I have to work with her regularly before realizing she was out,
I already bought flowers and put them on a desk in order to cover the stench of
my own failure. Now Dude, you can't. He goes,
cause she knows what you really think.
Okay.
I'm guessing I shouldn't leave them there.
Let her come back to dead flowers either. Congratulations on your baby girl.
And of course you laid a special sincerely, I'd done fucked up.
Um,
where is she on vacation and is there a way to unsend all of those text
messages? That's what I would try to do over the next 10 days.
I would not apologize anymore. I would not give flowers.
And this is what you got to do, Dude.
You got a fucking man up and when she calls you out on it, be like, Yep,
I was, I'm not going to tell you who I was sending it to.
Don't rat out the other person on any fucking level.
Do not rat out the other person you piece of shit if you do it.
Do not rat them out. Um,
I would actually say I was actually sending it to this girl.
I know who doesn't work here. Okay. Just say that.
Um,
and I was pitched to her about people at work and when she calls you out,
I would just say, listen, you know what? No. Send sugarcoat in it.
You're supposed to be here at eight 30 show up at nine 45, 10 o'clock.
Get dog in.
It is setting a bad example and I like working hard and that text came from the
frustration of watching you working,
setting the example of not working up to your potential.
It makes it a bad experience out here. So that's why I did it. If you mad at me.
I understand, but you know I stand by that text message.
I shouldn't have called you a bitch.
I was just saying that the way you know Richard Pryor says it.
I was just trying to be funny. But you know
you showing up an hour and 15 to an hour and a half late everyday is not good
for the, the morale around the office. That's what, that's where that came from.
So there you go. And I'm sorry I sent it to you, but you know
that's it. Fuck it.
Fuck it. That's all. That's the only card you got to play. Be like, yeah,
I sent it.
Although you did fucking put your hat in your hand and apologize. Yeah.
Boy, can you please write back and let me know how it pans out.
I'd love to know. All right. With that. That is the podcast for this week.
Um,
I'll check in on your, on Thursday. And uh,
this time next week I will be in Phoenix,
Arizona doing two shows a night at a commodity club,
also known as a comedy club and
uh,
be fucking polishing up this fucking hour so I can go on the road.
Not Embarrass myself like this guy did with his text message.
You pour bears too. We've all been there. You know what?
Even the lady that you're writing to, I bet she's done it too. Um,
but she's letting you squirm or,
or she's in Aruba or she someplace where she didn't get the text message and
maybe you can undo it.
Maybe you can fucking undo what was already done. This is,
this is another fucking movie. This is a fucking movie.
This is like weekend at Bernie's meets, uh, Steve Jobs.
Fucking one of those things when we used to walk out and be like, look,
now you can swipe texts. And everyone's like, oh right. That's what you do.
If you get fired, sir, you should write a fucking script.
Write a fucking script about somebody who sent the wrong text message to their
boss, sent a text message to the wrong person. That person's on vacation.
Okay? And then eventually you're going to have to fly down there.
You know that you can coast. Start with the guy with the eyes. You know,
he said the ice thing that he got from fucking out pachino where was,
what was the name of that actor he was in about last? Andrew McCarthy, right?
You guys, maybe you can fucking executive producer. See that.
That's the great thing about entertainment. No matter how bad you fuck up in it,
it makes the more you fuck up on your personal life,
the more material you get as a comedian, you get a script out of it.
I Dunno,
you don't sound fulfilled. Maybe. Maybe you could be a script writer. All right,
that's it. Go fuck yourselves. Your [inaudible] and I'll,
I'll talk to you on Thursday.